こんにちはユーチューバー捕獲委員会委員長はじめそうですよろしくお願いします
皆さん youtube が捕まえたことありますでしょうかまあ今世の中には
いろんなユーチューバーがたくさんいるんですけどもどんどんユーチューバーにも特徴
があるのでその特徴さえつかめばどんなユーチューバーでもあなたの家で捕まえること
ができるかも知れませんで僕一回
に捕まえたことがの湯チューバーがいますってヒカキンさん捕まえたことがありますか
議員さんは3件ですが大好きなのでサングラスはこう眺めておくとエステやサングラス
で香水寄せられてヒカキンさんが来るという見事大成功してヒカキンさんを捕まえた
ことがあるんですけども今回捕まえようと思うユーチューバーはこんな方
精勤さんですで生
ちーさんなんですけどもいろいろ調査をした結果あのユーチューバーの特徴としまして
はチョコエッグが大好きだということがわかっておりますので今回こちらに大量の
チョコいくをず観させていただいたんですけども整形じゃチョコよく大好きすぎて一
時期すごいちょブックの動画を通してたんですけどもう最近だしてないんですよ7ヶ月
前にですねチョコ1個120分配布するよ
凄くないですか普通の人間はそういう120個も買えませんからね投稿が整形さんの
ポイントなんですよ打者に見抜いてしまいましたそこが製品さんの弱点あの
ユーチューバーはチョコエッグが大好きです語一句に目がないそしてここ7ヶ月
しょぼいっても動画を出していないということは製品さんの心の中に秘めたるチョコ
エッグに対する直行えっ蚊よけが麦芽
寸前ねもうあの人へまあすごい込めるといてもたってもいられないくらい興奮して
しまうそんな極限の状態なんですけど政金さんはそんな中ですよ
モス
大量のチョコ1個が並べてあったら多分製品さんはチョコいくが好きなんできますも
静岡に来てこのパチ吸い寄せられてちょっと行くなとを伝って捕獲ポイントまで流動
できると思うので今日の動画は大量のチョコ1個使って生菌さんを捕獲してみようと
思いますでは直接化し配球で刺す口かけていこうと思いますよしかけっ
さあ的にこの方見ているうちに捕まえようかなって感じですね
融資
[音楽]
まあ知ってきましたご覧ください
後方てまず玄関までいいで亜型レッド中にまたあるので
を旅行行って言って曲がらせますつながって動くあっちょいって
で階段になってるんでこのも階段を登っていただきますと
[音楽]
そして階段の先に
ずっと奥まで行くとなど3つも最後至るんですせー金さんはもう一個にちょっと一句だ
と満足しないので最後に3つあることによって大興奮を起こしますここを捕まえる
ポイントとしますその生時代遅れが童顔と怪しいんですけども僕に論から言うとこれで
政金さんは捕獲することができると思いますでは来るの
根気強く待つ場所
[音楽]
me
持っています
ん
言われん
思っています
ん
[音楽]
ていません
ています
んだこれうわぁああこうなってんだ
a というか
アーム甲府工に行けということこれ
me
おっん
ん
持っていた
を
[音楽]
ああこれがいい
動画で見たわこれ
car
誰も言えねぇよぞ
20が買っていっ
そして
[音楽]
いやー
あああああん
me
yeah
teame
me
バッハ
あっはぁなんどりゃー
なんでこれでもう一個スレじゃなかったら
t さんが使われるかどうかでした無事引っかかってくればねぇくださあねいっぱいを
全部持ってきた方がいいのかなあこっちまで落ちきれないだろっは
レイヤーだけどみんなもぜひ戦記さんを捕まえてみようねえ捕まえよう